the first rule
which is kind of a comical rule
is stand up straight with your shoulders
back
and it's a meditation among other things
on the habits of lobsters i was reading
these these articles on lobsters and i
i
came across this this finding that
lobsters lobsters governed their
postural flexion with serotonin and i
thought god that's so interesting it's
so inflection is this is to stand up
straight i thought wow that's so
interesting because you know depressed
people crouch over i wonder if there's
any link between those two things and
then i went and read a whole
pile of papers on lobster and lobster
neurochemistry
lobster neurochemistry is actually quite
well understood because they have a
fairly simple nervous system right and
and so if you want to understand a
complex nervous system it's a good idea
to
understand a simple one first and then
sort of elaborate upwards and it turns
out that um
serotonin governs status
it governs status emotional regulation
and posture in lobsters just like it
does in human beings and so that would
just blew me away and so one one one
thing that the chapter one is about is
the fact that if a lobster is defeated
in a dominance battle
you can give it essentially
antidepressants and it will fight again
and that just blew me away you know it's
so it's so remarkable because one of the
things that tells you is that so if
you're
imagine that you could be
lobster
top dog or bottom dog imagine there's 10
strata in the lobster hierarchy so you
could be number one right top lobster
number 10 bottom lobster
if you're bottom lobster you have low
serotonin levels and high octopamine
levels that's a neurochemical that human
beings don't produce
and if you're a top lobster you have
high serotonin levels and low octopamine
levels and
you can move a lobster in its dominant
hierarchy by
moderating its levels of serotonin and i
thought that's so interesting because
what it means is that the counter that
keeps track of our status and we have a
counter in a sense in our minds that
keeps track of our status is a third of
a billion years old and what that also
means is that
the
the idea of the hierarchy let's call it
a dominance hierarchy because it within
lobsters it's it's kind of like a
physical prowess hierarchy something
like that the idea of the hierarchy is
at least 350 million years old
and so i read that and i think
well so much for the idea that
human hierarchies are a socio-cultural
construct it's like no that's wrong
it's not just a little bit wrong it's
unbelievably wrong it's mind-bogglingly
wrong right and it's
right and so so hierarchies hierarchies
have been around for a third of a
billion years and and we have a
neurochemical system that modulates our
our
understanding of those hierarchies and
then also this is the interesting thing
too and this is why people's reputations
are so important to them
among there's lots of reasons but this
is one of them is that
where this counter that you share with
lobsters rates you in terms of your
hierarchical position
determines the ratio of negative emotion
to positive emotion that you feel
and that's also an absolutely
mind-boggling idea for two reasons one
is it tells you why it's so hard on
people to be put down
because it doesn't just upset them in
the moment it changes the way their
entire system responds to the world so
that they now experience more positive
emotion and less less negative emotion
so that's really rough and then there's
a corollary to that too which is like
there's a very tight relationship
between your belief system and your
dominance hierarchy position it's
complicated but it's worth going through
like let's say that
so i have a certain amount of status as
a professor and and and and i have the
let's call it the uh
what would you say i've been granted the
entitlement to a certain position in a
in a social hierarchy now the question
is why
do i have a valid claim to that position
and the answer hypothetically is because
i know enough so that my claim to the
position is valid so then if you stand
up in the audience and challenge my
beliefs and show that i'm wrong you
might you might say well i get upset
because i'm wrong but the more accurate
reason that i get upset is because
you're indicating to the crowd that my
my position in the hierarchy of
authority is invalid
and by doing that you lower me in the
hierarchy and you mess around with the
neurochemical systems that are
regulating my emotions you want to
present yourself to the world in a
manner that
that doesn't disgrace you in some sense
that that might be a good way to think
about it and you don't want to disgrace
yourself because the consequence of
disgrace is is emotional dysregulation
more pain less positive emotion and so
the best way to present yourself is to
stand up forthrightly and to stretch out
you know and to occupy some space and to
to to you make yourself sort of
vulnerable by doing that because you
open up the front of your body right but
it's a sign of confidence and that way
people are most likely to give you the
benefit of the doubt
and that's a good way to start
regulating your mood but not only does
it directly regulate your mood to stand
up because it's so tightly associated
like posture reflection is associated
with serotonin and emotional regulation
but also because
if you straighten up and you present
yourself in that manner then other
people are more likely to take you
seriously and that means they'll start
treating you as if you're a number one
lobster instead of a number 10 lobster
and that's another way that you can
at least give yourself the bloody
benefit of the doubt right and and
and and and and confront the world in a
courageous manner and that's a really
good way of also of
of
figuring out how to establish yourself
in multiple competence hierarchies
because one of the general rules of
thumb about how to be successful is to
confront things that frighten you
forthrightly and with courage and that's
kind of a universal strategy for success
want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you too you've got michael jordan level
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe life and learn the 12
rules from jordan peterson that will
change your life enjoy
rule number two treat yourself like you
matter treat yourself like someone you
are responsible for helping
i mean it's it seems pretty clear to me
what this means yeah well that's an
investigation into why people don't
treat themselves well and the thing is
is that you know human beings are
self-conscious
and we know
about our limitations and we know about
our weaknesses
and so we can have contempt for human
beings in general because you know we're
just
flawed and breakable in all of that and
but we know ourselves better than we
know everyone else and so
unless you're narcissistic and some
people are
then you have a very acute sense of
how you're not up to scratch in in on
many of the dimensions along which you
could be evaluated even by yourself and
so that leads naturally to a sort of
contempt self-contemptuous attitude and
you can see that one of the stories i
talk about is that people are more
likely to give prescription medication
to their pets than to take them
themselves
right right you know
so
even in the united states because we're
pretty over medicated here
even in the united states while people
will get the prescriptions but they
won't take the pills
anyways the idea there is
it's it's sort of a
uh a variation that i learned from carl
young on treat other people as it as you
would like to be treated it's you
reverse that it's like
imagine someone that you treat well
that you love
then try to treat yourself that way you
got to detach from yourself a bit you
got to think okay well
i'm a person among other people and i
deserve at least as much respect as a
person among other people and
i should be trying to help myself across
time and instead of being
self-contemptuous and self-destructive i
need to
take care of myself as if i'm
potentially valuable and to lay out my
life that way and so that's what that's
that chapter is about
and it's
it it's hard for people you know they
don't take care of themselves as well as
they should and i don't mean you know
take care of yourself i mean that is
what i mean it's like
it's not a moralistic
attack
it's like it's an encouragement to
give yourself a bit of the benefit of
the doubt and
and treat yourself as if you have some
intrinsic value rule number three make
friends with good people the next rule
is
make friends with people who want the
best for you
and that's a meditation on my own
childhood and adolescence to some degree
i had friends who wanted the best for me
and friends who didn't and you know they
were friends who
some of them were aiming up and some of
them were aiming down and if you have a
friend that's aiming down and you do
something that's aiming up then they're
generally not that happy about it you
know they try to top your accomplishment
with one of their own hypothetical or
real or put down what you're doing or
offer you a cigarette if you're trying
to quit and you've kind of done that
successfully or a drink if you've been
drinking too much and are trying to stop
being an alcoholic you know or or
yeah they're cynical and bitter and and
devoted towards no good and sometimes
that's family members too and sometimes
it's even part of you you know but
this chapter is a injunction to people
is like
like you have an ethical responsibility
to take care of yourself you have an
ethical responsibility to surround
yourself with people who have the
courage and
and faith and
wisdom to wish you well when you've done
something good
and to stop you when you're doing
something destructive and if your
friends aren't like that then they're
not your friends
and maintaining your friendships with
them might not even be in their interest
and so it's a tricky argument to make
because i'm not saying you know whenever
anyone's in trouble you should you know
push them into a ditch and then give
them a couple of kicks that's that's not
the idea
the idea is that but i had a couple of
rules i didn't write about one was be
careful
uh be careful about whom you share good
news with and another was be careful
about whom you share bad news with and
everyone those rules ring in people's
minds quite quickly a friend is someone
you can share good news with you know
you go to them and you say hey look this
good thing happened to me and they say
look i'm so happy that that happened to
you like way to be and they don't think
god damn it why didn't that happen to me
and like you know you didn't deserve it
here's a bunch of reasons you're stupid
and why it won't work it's like that's
not helpful and so i would say like if
people are
you know what the other thing people are
doing if they're trying to drag you down
let's say is they're trying to see if
you'll put up with it because they have
this idea that maybe life isn't worth
living and things aren't good and then
if they can be
let's say to use an archaic term
something that's pristine and good then
they demonstrate to themselves that
there is no true ideal and that there's
no necessary reason to be responsible
and to strive forward and so they use
you it's a test case you know i'll just
push you down into the low lobster bin
and see how you respond and if you put
up with it then yeah my cynicism is
fully justified rule number four compare
yourself to who you were yesterday
compare yourself to who you were
yesterday not to who someone else is
today yeah well you've got to improve
right
and so
and you might think well i'm a real
fixer-upper and i'm really embarrassed
about that because there's 50 things
wrong with me and like look at that guy
and so now i feel all terrible because
of the comparison and all of that and
first of all it's unfair because
especially by the time you're about 30.
when you're 17 you're like every other
17 year old and so that kind of social
comparison is more appropriate by the
time you're about 30 your life has
become quite idiosyncratic you know like
let's say your life has eight dimensions
family friends intimate relationships
health you know you can kind of
lay them out
you're
individually
positioned in all those dimensions your
life isn't like anyone else's life and
so you see someone who's doing better
than you it's like you're only seeing
one dimension at one slice of time so
it's not reasonable you know what you
don't have the whole picture
you know
so and then you you get down on yourself
and and take the spirit out of yourself
and you get bitter and resentful it's
like there's nothing good about that
yeah so so but you do need to improve
because there's more to you than there's
not as much of you as there should be so
what's the comparison well that's easy
you just say okay well here here's my
position in time and space right now
here's my
virtues and faults it's like i can be a
little bit better tomorrow in some minor
way well that's the right comparison
because
you are very much like you you know you
know what i mean everything's the same
about you yeah and so it's a perfect
comparison and then you get a trajectory
going it's like well
obviously i'm not perfect but i'm
slightly less terrible than i was
yesterday man you keep that up for five
years
and you're wherever you should be that
isn't where someone else should be right
because you really are an individual you
just don't have insight into the tragedy
of someone else's life you know and you
might think well he's rich and
successful it's like yeah but you just
don't know you don't know what his
relationship is with his wife or his
children you know you don't know that
he's gone through two divorces and his
daughter won't talk to him and one of
his kids is schizophrenic and like most
people's lives are pretty nicely
saturated with tragedy you know and with
a certain degree of malevolence and you
might think well i'd trade places with
him in a minute and i'm also not saying
that some people don't have it really
rough it's like look man some people
have it rough yeah that's not the point
it's not the point the point is
you should be better than you are but
it's not because you're worse than other
people it's because you're not
everything you should be and so you got
to pick the comparison right and then
that's also ennobling it's like an
instantly hopeful there is absolutely no
doubt that you can be slightly better
tomorrow than you are today
and then
because of the pareto principle that you
know that that movement towards the good
increases exponentially that trajectory
can just take you out of hell very very
rapidly and so you know there's nothing
but good
about that rule number five don't let
your children do anything that makes you
dislike them do not let your children do
anything that makes you dislike them
and i thought that would be contentious
first of all because people would think
well i never dislike my children it's
like
really
really
really you know you're going to really
tell me that god
you know when there's a more there's a
more horrifying element to that too
because as a clinical psychologist i've
seen the full freudian nightmare i can
tell you that and you know the i've seen
families where it's like this is like
the family members are standing in a
circle let's say and each of them has
their hands around each other's neck and
they're squeezing
hard enough to strangle the other person
in 20 years and that's the family it's
like and you know if you if you haven't
met a family like that or
well then you're not paying attention
and there's
there's some reasonable possibility that
you're actually in a family like that
so the idea that parents
can't dislike their children it's like
god how naive can you get it's just
that's just
if you think that man you i don't even
know where you'd start to straighten
yourself out i could never dislike my
children's like
yeah well those are the people who
produce the most monstrous children too
i can tell you that see i kind of knew
this when i had my kids i had already
undergone that to some degree and and
understood what it meant to be a bad
person a terrible person
and one of the things i knew that was
that that manifested itself in families
all the time tyrannical father
overprotective mother more rarely
overprotective mother tyrannical
overprotective father tyrannical mother
it's usually the other way around um and
the terrible pathological familial drama
that freud made much of in the early
20th century i'd seen that in many many
situations
dismal brutal awful
and i've seen parents punish their
children and
you can also take a page from nietzsche
if you really want to punish your
children or anyone else if you have
someone you're interested in punishing
um including yourself you don't you
don't ever punish someone you really
want to punish for doing something wrong
because that's actually a bit of a
relief to them you know that's the theme
of dostoevsky's crime and punishment
the murderer gets away with it and it's
a relief to him when he gets caught it's
like no if you really want to punish
someone you wait till they do something
good
then you punish them
because that'll teach them that's you
maximize the hurt that way you decrease
the probability that they'll ever do
anything good again and i'll tell you
man if you want to have a good
relationship with someone that's one
thing you don't do you open your bloody
eyes and if they do something that you
would like them to do again
then you
tell them how much you appreciated the
fact that that happened and you hope
that it replicates you know you see
that that's if there's one thing you can
take away from tonight's lecture that's
that's an extraordinarily useful thing
to know watch and when people do
something that they should do more of
say look i saw that you did this
specific thing i saw that it took some
effort here's what it meant here's
here's how i observed it's like keep
that up and man if you love someone you
do that to them that's that's
encouragement that's such a great thing
so
anyways back to children so i already
knew that i was pretty decent monster by
the time i had kids and i thought well
my kid my kids little you know like a
baby or two year olds like i'm a
horrible monster and so there's an
uneven power problem here i better not
let that child do anything that really
makes me angry
you know now you hear now and then you
hear about something horrible that
happens i when i was in boston years ago
i read about a woman who plunged her
two-year-old daughter's arms into
boiling water you think well how in the
world can that happen it's like well you
know
she's probably hungover she probably
just lost her job
she was probably desperate in six
different ways she probably didn't have
any decent discipline at her
disciplinary strategies for children she
probably didn't have anyone helping her
she was bitter and resentful and angry
and the child misbehaved at exactly the
wrong moment and like you're going to be
around your children a lot and so you
might want to have it so that they don't
misbehave at exactly the wrong moment
because all hell can break loose if they
can and i didn't want that to happen so
and i knew that it was easy for people
to hate their children even though they
mouth the words that they love them all
the time i saw very little evidence of
that many situations and so
one of the things you know you have a
natural affinity for children and even
more maybe a more powerful natural
affinity for your own children so that's
a good start but you don't want to set
them up as an enemy against you you
don't want to allow them to engage in
the kind of hierarchical challenge that
makes you irritable and resentful that's
not a good idea and if the things they
do make you dislike them the probability
that they will make other people dislike
them is extraordinarily high and so you
can consult your own irritability and
you can say look kid i used to tell my
kids this you know when they were three
or four i'd say look i'm not in a very
good mood and i'm likely to be
unreasonable so it'd be best if you'd go
in your room and play for a while it's
like i like you man you're a great kid
but like get the hell out of here for a
while you know and they were fine with
that we'd train them already at that
point to be able to go play by
themselves in the room you know which is
something a kid should be able to do
anyways but but you need to know what
sort of monster you are if you're going
to be a good parent and if you think oh
i'm not a monster it's like oh yes you
are you're just an unbelievably
unconscious monster and that's actually
the worst kind so and then the other
thing about that chapter is there's an
idea in it and and it's an idea that i
think's well supported by the relevant
literature which is that your
fundamental job as a parent especially
of a child from zero to four is to make
that child eminently desirable socially
so what you're you're a successful
parent if when your child is four
all sorts of other children want to play
with him or her that's really the that's
like if you want one marker of whether
or not you've been successful that's it
now some children are a lot harder to
get along with than others and some
children have a harder time playing and
so i'm not saying that every parent who
has a child that isn't popular at four
is is at fault for that i'm not saying
that i'm saying the reverse which is you
can be sure that you've been successful
if your child is not popular exactly but
desirable as a playmate and so then you
think well what have you done for your
child well you've opened up the entire
world of children to them so because
they know how to play which is a very
deep knowledge and it starts to become
inculcated probably at the breast and
certainly in the course of rough and
tumble play at about two years of age
it's a deep embodied knowledge they know
how to play like a good well-trained dog
knows how to play you know you meet a
new dog and you go like this and the dog
goes like this you think oh that dog it
i can go like this and it won't bite me
right it knows how to play and a kid
who's awake and alert is just like that
like a well-socialized kid if you know
anything about kids is you can take a
four-year-old and make a little play
gesture at them and they'll smile right
away and start playing just right now
and that's what you want for your kids
and then everywhere they go other kids
like them and will include them in their
play and play as the way the children
develop and so if other children include
them in their play then the children
develop and the poor kids that don't get
befriended at the age of four with the
literature on this is crystal clear if
your child is an outcast at the age of
four the probability that anything can
be done about that is almost zero no
matter what you do and i hate to be so
blunt about that but i know the
literature and that's what the
literature suggests
and so and then the other thing is if if
you don't allow your children to engage
in dislikable behavior then adults will
like them because adults actually like
kids you know one of the things i loved
about having little kids in montreal i
lived in a poor area in montreal there's
a lot of rough guys around there and we
used to roll our daughter around in a
stroller and these rough guys you know
like
god only knows what they were up to
they're rough looking guys you know we'd
roll our daughter by them and they'd
they'd like smile and they'd crouch down
and make little goo faces and you know
they were
you i tell you one of the great things
about having little kids is they bring
out the best in other people you see a
whole side of humanity even among the
darker parts of humanity you see a whole
side of them that you wouldn't normally
see and it's lovely and the thing is if
you're good to your kid in the real way
you can help them maintain that
tremendous attractiveness that they have
as young children and to respond to
adults properly like a puppy that wags
its tail instead of growls and you know
goes for your ankle and then wherever
they go adults welcome them and teach
them things and pat them on the head and
smile at them genuinely instead of
saying oh my god here comes that couple
with that goddamn brat again you know
which is the horrible that's horrible
thing to do to a child because then
everywhere they go all the good all the
good will is false
you know there's nothing that you can do
to someone that's more terrible than to
put them in a world where all the good
will directed towards them is false
that's a terrible thing rule number six
set your house in perfect order before
you criticize the world rule number six
set your house in perfect order before
you criticize the world oh that's a
rough one that's about us that's about a
mass murderer and about mass murderers
yeah so i didn't i didn't get this far
because as i said i just got this
yesterday man well
there's plenty of things to criticize
about being
it's tragic
and there's malevolence that's basically
the issue
and
you can complain about that but the
thing is if you complain about that if
you adopt that attitude which is sort of
an anti-being attitude you go places
that
if you knew you were going you probably
wouldn't want to go
it's the places where like the kids that
showed up columbine went those are bad
places like you if you read the writings
of the columbine high school kids and
you really read them
if they don't make the hair stand up in
the back your neck you are not paying
attention like the one kid wrote things
i cannot believe
that people could write
and i've exposed myself to a lot of
crazy things that people have done and
said
you just can't understand it it's it's
it's uncanny you know
well that's where you end up if you're
if you get bitter it's like well what
can you do about that well the world is
harsh it's like
should you criticize it it's like not
until you put yourself together
you've got to bring everything you can
to bear on the problem before you have
any right to
stand in judgment about being itself and
that's what these mass murderers do
that's what they're doing that's what
they're acting out
they're saying well i'm looking out in
the world
i don't like people
they're full of flaws they act badly
they're a cancer on the face of the
planet it'd be better if they didn't
exist at all
so
i don't like being it's too full of
suffering and and evil
i'm the judge of this
it's like i'm going to make my goddamn
case i'm going to take them out
and then it's more than that it's like
i'm going to take them out and i'm going
to do it with the innocence first
because that's the thing you got to get
about the mass murderer types is like
they're not hunting down the guilty
that's too obvious right you're hunting
down the innocent that's the best
protest that's why the guy showed up the
elementary school in connecticut
it's like why do you shoot kids well
think about it well i don't want to
think about it well that's for sure you
bloody well don't want to think about it
but you better think about it
it's like well that's where you go when
you take that criticism of being
approached it's like you don't get to do
that not unless you want to end up there
it's bad
so what do you do instead it's like okay
stop doing stupid things stop lying stop
making things worse stop making yourself
weak
you know everyone does that they know it
you know and i'm not saying follow the
rules i'm not saying that i'm saying
even in a day you'll see that you have
choices in front of you and sometimes
you don't know what to do it's okay
you're ignorant maybe you make a mistake
whatever
that's just ignorance
malevolence is when you know what you
shouldn't do
and you do it anyways and people do that
all the time and that's arrogance that's
i'll get away with it it's okay it's
deceit because you're lying to yourself
about whether you should do this or not
you know you shouldn't right you know
and then it's resentment because well
it's like i'm gonna do this bad thing
because that'll teach the people or
whatever that'll teach god to treat me
this way it's like that's
that's the that's the terrible trinity
deceit arrogance resentment it's like
chase those out of your life
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number seven do what is
meaningful not what is expedient rule
seven rule seven just about killed me
like i i've had a lot of bad health in
the last year and
having to rewrite rule seven coincided
with one of those periods that lasted
about a month and it was was the hardest
chapter by far and it went down the
deepest by far and it was really hard to
get right it's called do what is
meaningful
not what is expedited and i'll just tell
you a little bit about the chapter
because i figured something out in it
that
and then explained it something that
took me decades to figure out so there's
this idea it's a it's a very deep
christian idea that the messiah is the
person who takes the world's sins upon
himself right that's a characteristic of
christ right it's something the idea is
something like christ died for your sins
it's like what the hell does that mean
exactly you know and partly what it
means and i would say a slightly
corrupted form of christianity is that
you just have to believe that that
happened in the and you're redeemed it's
like
well that's
we'll leave that aside for a second but
there's an idea there a psychological
idea you know that because the idea
doesn't go away it's lasted for
thousands of years it's like well so the
idea signifies something it has a
psychological reality independent of its
metaphysical reality whatever that might
be and so i thought about that for a
long time it's like what in the world
does that possibly mean and then i
realized and jung knew this carl jung
knew this that it was associated with
this idea of the shadow
i had this client once who
[Music]
her parents man they were pieces of work
she
her parents taught her i swear to you
that this is the truth her parents
taught her that adults were angels
literally
and when i saw her she was about 30 and
she had a lot of strange symptoms
symptoms of sorts i'd never seen
psychosomatic symptoms
she she uh
she had kind of like quasi-epileptic
seizures at night and no but she stayed
conscious during them it was very
difficult to understand it and i won't
walk through it but her parents told her
that adults were angels and uh
and she was like 28 she had a university
degree and and i said well
did he ever
like wonder about that i said didn't you
read any history and she said yeah what
i read something about the terrible
things that people did to each other and
i would just compartmentalize it
and that was actually the key that i
used to unlock what was wrong with her
which was eventually fixed and i won't
go into that but but i said i gave her
this book i gave her two books i gave
her a book called uh the terror that
comes in the night which is a book about
um
about
sleep paralysis and nightmares because i
thought that was what might have been
bothering her turned out that wasn't it
then i gave her this other book called
ordinary
ordinary men
and it's a great book it's a terrible
book terrible dark book about
about this police battalion that was
moved into poland during world war ii
after the nazis had marched through and
it was all made of middle-aged guys who
weren't like victims of nazi
totalitarian propaganda when they were
kids they were just you know bourgeois
middle class guys kind of like all of us
let's say um and they went to to police
poland and um
they were going to have to do some
terrible things essentially but their
commander told them quite forthrightly
that if
being involved in wartime policing was
too hard on them if they felt that it
ethically violated them or
psychologically violated they could just
go back to policing in germany and very
few of them did partly because they
didn't want to abandon their
comrades let's say they didn't want them
to have to do the dirty work you know
and they ended up they were normal
policemen they ended up the sorts of
people who could take naked pregnant
women out into the middle of the field
and shoot them in the back of the head
that's how the book that's the
culmination of their training it's very
interesting to read about their training
because they were absolutely sickened by
what they learned to do like physically
sick and vomiting shaking traumatized
but they didn't stop and and if you want
to know why then you can read the book
and i said look
read this book but don't bloody well
compartmentalize it enough of that it's
like read it like you're one of the damn
policemen
which is how you should read history
right you read about nazi germany and
you think well i'm oscar schindler i'd
save the jews it's like no you wouldn't
right
you wouldn't because people didn't
and the probability is very high that
you wouldn't and all you have to do is
think it through you know anne frank
it's like you're really going to put
your family at risk to hide
a group of another family in your attic
for like multiple years while there's
nazis parading the street and where if
you get exposed you all die
you're going to do that are you
it's like very unlikely and and no
wonder it's not surprising that it's
unlikely but you don't want to be
inflating yourself with self you know
with with fictional heroism without
actually knowing the facts on the ground
so i told her to read read it and to
understand that
the policemen were her
and that's the thing to understand
well
the idea that the savior is the person
who takes the world's sins upon himself
is exactly that
it's exactly the same idea
it's like
the way that
there stops being nazis
is for you to know
that the nazis were you
and for you to decide not to do that
again
but you have to know you see this is the
thing that people won't do
you have to understand that you could
not only do what the nazi camp guards
did in auschwitz but that you could
actually enjoy it
and then you have to decide that you're
not going to do that anymore rule number
eight tell the truth or at least don't
lie tell the truth or at least don't lie
this has been a sort of theme of
everything we've been talking about
well telling the truth
because you have to know the truth
and that's hard but you can
know when you're lying
you sometimes you don't know because
what the hell do you know
but sometimes you know
and you can feel that that's a
disjunction of meaning so you'll know
you see this often with people who are
very socially awkward you know they'll
say something that's sort of grandiose
and it really falls flat and everyone's
a bit embarrassed including them it's
like
they've
if they were paying attention they would
notice that that disunited them and made
them weak
and then they wouldn't say it and so
that's that's the thing about not lying
is that
lies make you weak and you can feel it
it's it's the antithesis of meaning i
would say because meaning is associated
with the truth so if you're if you're
lying you're you're at the opposite pole
of that that's the deceit part and it
makes you weak you think well i'll lie
and i'll get away with it it's like no
you won't
you you cannot get away with warping the
structure of being rule number nine
assume that others know something you
don't chapter nine is assume that the
person you are listening to might know
something you don't
this is a chapter about conversation and
about the different forms conversation
takes
it's a chapter about humility
and it's a chapter about listening and
the humility element is it took me a
long time to understand why there's
religious injunctions supporting
humility
to even understand what the word really
meant in that sort of technical sense
and it means something like this it
means what you don't know is more
important than what you know
and that's a lovely thing to
then then what you don't know can start
to be your friend you see people are
very defensive about what they know and
for the reasons we've already discussed
but the thing is
you don't know enough and the re you can
tell you don't know enough because your
life is not what it could be and neither
is the life of the people around you you
just don't know enough and so
what that means is that every time you
encounter
some evidence that you're ignorant
someone points it out you should be
happy about that because you think oh
you just told me how i'm wrong it's like
great like maybe i had to sift through a
lot of nonsense to get through the real
message that you're telling me but if
you could actually tell me some way that
i'm wrong and then maybe give me a hint
about how to not be wrong like that well
then i wouldn't have to be wrong like
that anymore that that would be a good
thing and you can you can you can embark
on that adventure by listening to people
and if you listen to people they will
tell you
they'll tell you amazing things if you
listen to them and many of those things
are little tools that you can put in
your toolkit like batman and then you
can go out into the world and use those
tools and you don't have to fall blindly
into a pit quite as often and so the
humility element is well
do you want to be right
or do you want to be learning and then
it's deeper than that it's do you want
to be that the tyrannical king who's
already got everything figured out or do
you want to be the continually
transforming hero or fool for that
matter who's getting better all the time
and that's actually a choice you know
it's a deep choice and it's better to be
the self-transforming fool who's
humble enough to make friends with what
he or she doesn't know and to listen
when people talk and
listening is a transformative exercise
like if if you listen to the people in
your life for example if you actually
listen to them they'll tell you what's
wrong with them and how to fix it and
what they want they can't even help it
if you start listening because people
are so shocked if you actually listen to
them that they tell you also those sorts
of things that they might not have even
intended to things they don't even know
and then you can
you can work with that
and so and the other thing that's so
interesting you know now and then you
have a meaningful conversation right you
have a good conversation with someone
you walk when you think geez you know
what we really connected and i know more
than i did when i came away from that
conversation and during the conversation
you're really engrossed in it
and that that that feeling of being
engrossed is a feeling of meaning and
the feeling of meaning is engendered
because you're having a transformative
conversation your brain produces that
feeling of meaning for you says oh yeah
this is exactly where you should be
right here and now it's
it's the right place and time for you
and that's a great place to occupy and
so a good conversation where people are
listening has exactly that nature and
the reason it has that nature is because
it is in fact transformative it's one of
the truisms of clinical psychology like
if you're a clinical psychologist a huge
part of what you do is just listen to
people
it's like you know
they come in they're unhappy and they'd
rather not be something like that you
say well
why do you think you might be unhappy
and they don't know they have some ideas
they may have to ramble around for like
a year before they figure out why
they're unhappy they get rid of a bunch
of reasons
why they thought they were unhappy that
are untrue and then you kind of get to
the heart of the problem then you might
ask them well
if you could have what you wanted so
that your life would be okay
what would that look like then they have
to ramble around a bunch about that
because they don't really know but the
listening will straighten them out
because people think by talking and in
order to think you have to have someone
to listen because it's very hard to
think hardly anyone can think and even
the people who can think can only think
about a limited number of things but
almost everybody can talk and you can
listen to yourself talk and if someone
listens to you then well then
you also have a foil for your thoughts
right because you can watch the person
when you're talking and see if you're
boring or see if you're amusing or if
you're engrossing all of those things
and so
listening that's a very good thing i
outline a carl rogers victim he was a
famous clinical psychologist this is
another great little tip rogers said
here's a trick to tell if you're
listening so let's say someone lays out
their perspective for you and then what
you do is say look here's what i think
you said
i think you said this and this and this
and this and then this
is that right have i got what you're
saying right and maybe the person says
god you haven't been listening at all
and you know then they have to
straighten you out or maybe they say
yeah yeah you got it
and then the nice thing about that is
that you summarize their argument for
them which can be very helpful and for
you but also
you don't get to make the person into a
straw man so like if you're arguing with
your wife let's say or your husband
big party is going to want to win
that's stupid because if you win you get
to be top lobster but they get to be
bottom lobster and if you want to live
with bottom lobster then like more power
to you but i wouldn't recommend it right
because you don't want that you want to
you want to defeat your wife in an
argument oh well great like if she was
going to disappear tomorrow no problem
but like you're going to like live with
defeated miserable her for the next week
that's no good so you listen and you
think okay well here's here's what you
what i think you said and maybe even
make it a little stronger and more
elaborated than was the case with the
original utterance so that you get the
damn argument right because you don't
want to win you want to fix the problem
that's the winning
and so the summary with listening is so
useful for that because the person can
say well yeah that's what i meant it's
like then well then you have to grapple
with that and roger said well people
usually won't because you know if you
live with someone and they tell you the
truth about the situation it usually
means that there's something really
stupid that you're doing you want them
to but there's something stupid that
you're doing that you know you're doing
that you actually have to stop and you
know that's difficult and unlikely but
well if you don't stop then you get to
have the same damn problem every day or
every week for the rest of your life so
it's probably better to undergo the
misery of stopping it than the misery of
continuing it but
that's the injunction to listen rule
number 10 be precise in your speech be
precise in your speech
so in in genesis one of the things god
has adam do first so god makes the world
by speaking okay so that's the first
thing to think about
you're supposed to think like
in a sophisticated way about this the
idea is that there's some integral
relationship between
communication and the structure of being
it's part of the role that consciousness
plays in the world whatever that role is
language
takes the chaos and makes it into things
and so
god has adam name all the animals
they're not even really real until they
have names
now
they're more implicit that's another you
know here's a here's an example let's
say that
you're having a rough patch in your
relationship
and you don't know why
it's unnameable is it real well yeah
it's manifesting itself in like a
physiological discomfort
then you talk about it and you name it
it's like it goes from this blurry thing
that's kind of potential it goes snap
and then it's this thing
right and then that's a horrible thing
it's like a little poisonous thing but
it's not a whole foggy cloud of
potential poison it's like this little
sharp poison thing and then you think
okay
it's real it's a little monster but it's
not it's little at least and now
probably we can do something about it if
we can admit to it so it's this
precision that specifies and like so
this is a little bit of the voldemort
effect right if since you're a harry
potter guy they wouldn't name it right
this is a problem we got to name them
first oh yeah you've got to name them
first absolutely because the unnamable
is far more terrifying than the nameable
you see that in there was this great
blair witch project terrifying movie
well it's unnamed
there's nothing terrible happens in that
movie it's all the unnamable it's like
what's going on what's going on what's
going on and
no matter how terrible the actuality is
it's rarely as terrible as your
imagination because your imagination
like it's an old thing it's seen a lot
of terrible things in the history of
life like it can put monsters everywhere
and so it's almost always better
it might be better without exception to
name the thing no matter how terrible it
is and if you can't name it what that
means is that you're you're telling
yourself that you're so terrified that
you can't bring your attention to bear
on it and that makes you you're the
loser instantly if it's so terrifying
that you cannot face it
it's one let's say we want to specify
something that's threatening think well
you know you shouldn't be prejudiced
against an entire group of people it's
like hey fair enough man of course yeah
but ideas have consequences and there is
religious conflict and there is
terrorism it's like okay
what do we make of that well the way you
figure that out is you have a
conversation about it stupidly you make
all sorts of mistakes you might even
make racist mistakes it's like well what
is this thing
how are we supposed to get our hands
around it so how are we supposed to know
what it is well you can't talk about it
because that's bad it's like
it's not as bad as what you conjure up
if you can't talk about it okay then
it's the devil himself i mean that's how
we that's how we
um
demonize people the worst way of
demonizing people is to not be able to
say anything about them because then god
only knows what they're unspeakable
there isn't a better
synonym for what's terrifying than
that's unspeakable what you did was
unspeakable it's like
no no you want to bring things out of
the realm of the unspeakable that's why
i'm a free speech advocate yeah part
it's like
bring everything out of the realm of the
unspeakable because it's also the direct
attack on the intellect isn't it it's a
direct attack if you can't speak about
something you can't exercise it's just
going to make that box around your brain
that much
deeper than the intellect
it's an assault on
whatever role consciousness has in being
it's not just the intellect like that's
that that's that's a shallower thing
it's not like it's not important
it's you can't even attend to it you
can't bring it out of the chaos like it
means you you can't participate in the
process of creation it's something that
deep
not good for like freedom of speech
that's that's the worship of the logos
in many ways and you know that's a
that's a very deep idea in our culture
the deepest idea of our culture is the
logos is creative and what it makes is
good
right that's that's god at the beginning
of time saying
you know he makes things as a
consequence of the logos and he says
it's good that's the idea
is that to bring things out of the murk
is a good thing
you don't mess with that man not unless
you want merc
you don't mess with that it's the
fundamental
it's the most sacred principle of
western civilization and not only
western the taoists know this as well
rule number 11 do not bother children
when they're skateboarding rule 11 is
don't bother children when they're
skateboarding and that's a meditation on
the difference between weakness and
goodness
you see one of the things that's
happened in our society
and especially with regards to our
attitude towards men but also our
attitude towards the masculinity in
women so it's just as toxic for women is
that we seem to have concluded that
strong men are dangerous and that's
partly because we think
western culture is a tyrannical
patriarchy and the only reason you get
to the top is because you misuse power
and so all the men who are
at the top of the heart you're all
misusing their power and they're all
tyrannical and all the guys who have the
aim and ambition to achieve that are
just tyrants in training and that's sort
of the basic attitude that we have
towards our own culture and towards
young men now and that's just
there's
everything about that is pathological
and inexcusable and shameful i mean
first the claim that western culture
the idea that western culture is
primarily a patriarchal tyranny is like
well first of all it's it's historically
ignorant beyond belief because what do
you compared to what exactly
like how many civilized countries are
there in the world
you know three dozen
the rest of them are run by brutal thugs
right and it isn't just thugs at the top
man because that isn't how it works
and in a country that's corrupt the
corruption has spread through the entire
country
so
and we're not like that and that's that
i mean western culture is fundamentally
honest and i can give an example of that
because people don't like that idea ebay
proved that
because here it did it did it was a very
interesting thing because when ebay
first popped up like the cynic would say
ebay is not going to work because
i don't know you you live in the other
side of the country you're going to send
me junk and i'm going to send you a
check that bounces and that'll be the
end of ebay right
right that's what a cynic would say and
then what happened was that brokers
popped up and they said well look we'll
guarantee the exchange rights for a fee
10 we'll make sure that you don't send
junk and we'll make sure your check
doesn't bounce and what happened was the
brokers couldn't find enough business
and the reason for that was all the
transactions were honest
all of them
you know it's like 19 if you were on
ebay and you have a reputation of less
than 99 there's actually something wrong
with you you know okay 98 but really
it's that it's that tight and so the
default position was
you're offering this i'll buy it we'll
make the exchange fairly and what
happened was a bunch of capital that was
frozen technically speaking junk that
people had that other people could need
got freed up and ebay freed up a
tremendous amount of money for people
and it was all a consequence of default
honesty we also know that one of the
best predictors of success in western
world is conscientiousness and
conscientious people are honest and have
integrity and are dutiful and do what
they say they'll do and that's a really
good predictor of long-term life success
especially as a manager and
administrator something like that
so
also chapter 11 is a discussion about
the assault on the on the positive
masculine and i read it partly as a
continuation of what nietzsche announced
back in the late 1800s as the death of
god right because in western culture god
was a masculine figure and the idea that
the divine masculine had been decimated
which was basically nietzsche's
pronouncement has filtered all the way
down to masculinity itself and i think
that's an absolutely appalling
outcome it's it's it's something that
could only be desired by someone who is
a true enemy of humanity and so partly
chapter 11 is a call to encouragement
it's like you want and i've been telling
young men in particular but young women
as well though they don't seem to be
quite as in need of the message
to adopt responsibility for their life
to tell the truth and to understand that
their failure to participate fully in
being leaves a hole that's precisely the
size of their soul in the cultural
landscape
it's no joke we need all the light we
can possibly bring to bear on the
situation and
well and i firmly believe that and i
believe that for all sorts of reasons
and i think there are very deep reasons
um and that's partly why i would say
rules to life also has it's a funny book
because it has a very religious core but
it's also very heavily grounded in
evolutionary biology so
but that's what chapter 11
is about and it's about
people who are the enemy of the human
spirit the people who restrict
children's play for example which is a
particularly pathological thing to do
there's a movement now to not let
children have best friends it's like
really what the hell man and rule number
12 the last one before some very special
bonus clips is pet a cat when you
encounter one on the street pet a cat
when you encounter one on the street
well it's funny that you said you're a
dog guy because about the first three
pages of the chapter are actually an
apology for not including dogs okay
all right very good very good i start by
talking about dogs quite a bit actually
but well
that is a bit autobiographical i talk a
fair bit about my daughter in that and
she's actually vetted the chapter and
and helped me write it
um because i wrote about
tragedy really about pain
and and
well the pain of of caring for someone
especially with children you know
and
what you have to do when you're in a
situation where
tragic things are happening in front of
you and you're somewhat powerless in in
the face of them you know
and part of that is
you have to keep your eyes open for
for the little opportunities
for the redemptive elements of being to
sort of pop themselves up so i talk a
little bit about this cat that's across
the street named ginger
ginger is this
um
siamese cats really friendly made
friends with our dog just by refusing to
be afraid it would come over and the dog
would sort of bark and it would roll
over and like paw at him you know so
they were friends in no time and the cat
would just come over and
like
let you pet it and be happy with it for
a minute and that's
when things are
not good
and hard then you get these little
moments where
a little bit of possibility still shines
through and you got to take those
moments when you get them and so that's
what that chapter is about it's about
how to manage when things are too much
and there's some practical advice in
there like one of the things you have to
do when things are just
going to hell in a hand basket let's say
is you got to also shrink your temporal
horizon it's like you know you think
well i'm planning three months out it's
not not if you're on fire
you're planning for the next two seconds
you know and if things are really harsh
in your life someone's suffering around
you and you got too many problems it's
like you shrink your time frame to the
day
and you try to or the hour or the minute
you say okay well we've got to have the
best next minute we can have we've got
to have that's a deathbed thing too
right
it's like you sure you shrink the time
until you can handle it
there's no
not any more going on in that tiny
fragment of time than you can bear
that's how you adjust to the catastrophe
and you try to stay on your feet and
react during those periods of time and
so it's a bit of a discussion about
how you
reconfigure your perceptions of things
when
when
when there's too much pain and trouble
in your life so
it's it's actually a very positive
chapter even though it deals with very
you know harsh things it was
the most emotional chapter to write i
would say and my daughter's actually
doing quite well she's figured out a lot
of what was wrong with her that's great
an amazing tour de force of
of concentration and care you know i
can't believe she's managed it
um
so
it's a positive thing that the chapter
and
and you know it's a reminder to look for
what's meaningful and
soul
satisfying soul sustaining
even when you're
where you'd rather not be
stop doing the things that you know are
wrong
that you could stop doing
right so it's a fairly it's a fairly
limited attempt first of all we're not
going to say that you know
what the good is or what the truth is in
any ultimate sense but we will presume
that there are things that you're doing
that for one reason or other you know
are not in your best interests there's
something about them that you just know
you should stop they're kind of
self-evident to you other things you're
going to be doubtful about you're not
going to know
which way is up and which way is down
but there are things that you're doing
that you know you shouldn't do
now some of those you won't stop doing
for whatever reason you don't have the
discipline or maybe there's a secondary
payoff or you don't believe it's
necessary or it's too much of a
sacrifice or you're angry or resentful
or or afraid who knows so forget about
those for now
but there's another subset that you
could stop doing it might be little
thing well that's fine stop doing it
and see what happens and what will
happen is your vision will clear a
little bit
and then something else will pop up in
your field of apprehension that you will
also know you should stop doing and that
you could stop doing because you
strengthened yourself a bit by stopping
doing the particular stupid thing that
you were doing before that just puts you
together a little bit more and you could
do that
repeatedly for for an indefinite period
of time and and
you know that doesn't necessarily mean
that you're going to ever be able to
formulate a clear
and final picture of what constitutes
the truth
and the good but it does mean that
you'll be able to continually move away
from what's untruth and what's bad make
a damn schedule and stick to it okay so
what's the rule with the schedule
it's not a bloody prison
that's the first thing that people do
wrong they say well i don't like to have
follow a schedule it's like well what
kind of schedule are you setting up well
i have to do this then i have to do this
then i have to do this you know and then
i just go play video games because who
wants to do all these things that i have
to do it's like wrong
set the damn schedule up
so that you have the day you want
that's the trick it's like okay i've got
tomorrow if i was going to set it up so
it was the best possible day i could
have
practically speaking
what would it look like well then you
schedule that and obviously there's a
bit of responsibility that's going to go
along with that because if you have any
sense one of the things that you're
going to insist upon is that at the end
of the day you're not in worse shape
than you were that than at the beginning
of the day right because that's a stupid
day if you have a bunch of those in a
row you just dig you know you dig
yourself a hole and then you bury
yourself in it's like sorry that's just
not a good strategy it's a bad strategy
so maybe 20 of your day has to be
responsibility and obligation or maybe
it's more than that depending on how far
behind you are but even that you can you
can ask yourself okay well i've got
these responsibilities i have to
schedule the damn things in
what's the right ratio of responsibility
to reward and you can ask yourself that
just like you'd negotiate with someone
who was working for you it's like okay
you got to work tomorrow
okay so i want you to work tomorrow and
you might say okay well what are you
going to do for me
that makes it likely that i'll work for
you well you could ask yourself that you
know
maybe you do an hour of
responsibility and then you play a video
game for 15 minutes i don't know
whatever turns your crank man but you
know you have to negotiate with yourself
and not tyrannize yourself
like you're negotiating with someone
that you care for that you would like to
be productive and have a good life and
and that's how you make the schedule
it's like and then you look at the day
and you think well if i had that day
that'd be good
great you know and you you're useless
and horrible so you'll probably only hit
it with about 70 accuracy but that beats
the hell out of zero
right and if you hit it even with 50
accuracy another rule is well aim for 51
percent the next week or 50 and a half
percent for god's sake or because
you're you're going to hit that position
where things start to loop back
positively and spiral you upward when i
was a teenager
i mean i i did
god if i had to write a book about the
stupid things i did when i was a
teenager it'd be a very thick book and
it'd be a worse book if there were
photographs accompanying it
and you know but but i had this
advantage that young people today don't
have which was well when my day of
stupidity was over i could go home and
it was not there
you know like it wasn't on twitter it
wasn't on facebook there wasn't 20 of my
friends
communicating to me about you know what
foolish thing i did at the party the
night before and um
and young people now they're just
followed by
paparazzi essentially
and and i've watched that with the young
teenage daughters of many of my friends
uh because my kids were a little too old
for that to have actually have happened
to them but god it's miserable and um we
know that
there is some relationship between the
amount of time people use facebook for
example and their mental health which me
the more they use facebook the more
depressed they are and it might be that
the depression is driving the facebook
use but the causal pathway seems to be
the other way around which is
you know it's just
playing that unbelievably exposed social
game that's hard on people and these
aren't trivial technologies you know i
mean they're sha they're they're
transforming the way we communicate with
one another and that's and they're
they're completely uncontrolled
experiments we have no idea what the
medium or long-term consequences are
going to be and we'll never find out
either because of course the
communication landscape changes so
quickly that by the time you get adapted
to one
communication technology another one has
come along that's even more confusing
that you now have to master and so
well that's why it's necessary for
everyone to develop their own modicum of
wisdom i believe because
i i don't know how else we're going to
be able to deal with this
technological
transformation that's going to come acro
is already coming across us like a tidal
wave and you know you ain't seen nothing
yet the other people in silicon valley
have plans that
well
that that make you think that the whole
place should probably be bombed just for
the safety of the rest of us
you know because there's
there's tremendous danger in that
rapid acceleration of machine
intelligence and and we have no we have
absolutely no idea where that's headed
so and maybe it'll be great it's it's
possible it'll be great but
power cuts both ways so
hopefully we can we can control it with
our wisdom and that's pretty much up to
each of you to put your lives together
so you can make good decisions the other
thing you should do if you're not very
industrious
industrious is discipline yourself and
so what do you do with that
eat three times a day at regular meal
times that's a good thing to practice
because that starts to put some
stability into your life get up at the
same time i would highly recommend all
those young people out there who are
listening like you want to get a jump on
life get the hell out of bed in the
morning you know as i've got older i've
got up earlier and earlier now that's
partly because you don't need as much
sleep but it's also partly because i've
got more and more disciplined like get
up early in the morning and get your
things done man learn to get up at six
in the morning and you'll be one deadly
creature especially if you can get to
work you'll have half your damn day done
by the time other people haul their
sorry asses out of bed and so that's a
massive massive advantage look will
ferrell
warren farrell not the comedian warren
farrell the author he outlined data in
why men earn more which is a book i
would recommend by the way showing that
if you work 13 longer hours you make 40
percent more money
it's non-linear so you think why is that
well imagine you had 10 employees and
one of them works an extra 10 percent
it's not much
well how often is that person going to
be
promoted assuming you have a clue as a
boss
it's like you're going to look at the 10
people and you're going to think oh that
guy's always here like 45 minutes early
it's like why don't we give him the
promotion obviously right so these tight
these small edges that you can manage
like that work an extra 10 percent extra
13
have non-proportional payoffs that's
part of the pareto distribution
so
get
get your sleep cycle organized so you
get up in the morning learn how to do it
no excuses i'm too tired in the morning
i don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it
schedule your meals because that's a
good disciplinary routine
and then learn to use a calendar like
google calendar most of you many of you
out there do not use a calendar okay a
calendar is not a prison and it's not a
tyrant not if you use it properly
a calendar keeps anxiety at bay
it makes sure that you do what you need
to do which is important because
otherwise you fall behind but if you use
it properly though it's also
helps you plan what you want to do so i
could say well lay out your damn
calendar
and
design the days you would like to have
that's what your calendar is is for so
you can put in all sorts of things in
there you want to do and that would be
good for you and that's a really good
really good way to start being more
industrious
make a plan you need a plan for three
years
you need a plan for the next year you
need to plan for the next six months you
need to plan for the next three months
you need a plan for the week you need a
plan for the day you need to plan for
the hour
all of that all of that i make lists
constantly of what i have to do and
they're like daily weekly monthly yearly
right now i can't look out more than
about six months you know because my
life is too complicated and chaotic but
but you need a vision of who you could
be what character you could have three
to five years out you can't go much
farther than that because life is too
unpredictable i think to
make vision that's longer term than that
subject to
there's two too much chance associated
with it to spend a lot of time on maybe
you can stretch it to five years and in
rare cases you can have a 10-year goal
but it has to be pretty low resolution
but you want plans at all those levels
of resolution you want to write the
things down
and what because what are you going to
do you're going to stumble around and
get get what you need you're going to
stumble around and be useful to other
people and it's useful to be useful to
other people you know they want to work
with you then they want to do things
with you they want to have you around
they trust you they open up
opportunities for you and if you stumble
around like you're blind you're not
going to get anywhere and then you're
going to suffer and then you're going to
be bitter and then you're going to be
cruel so that's a that's hell that's a
bad outcome sometimes you know i can't
sleep at night because i'm thinking
about something and usually what i'll do
is go write it down i have some writing
to do so i get up and i go right down
what i'm thinking and that usually does
the trick but because i had been playing
with youtube
i thought well
i'll try making youtube video and
telling people what i'm thinking about
and see if that
performs the same uh function as writing
and to me the function of writing well
it's twofold one is conceivably to
communicate with people although the
fundamental purpose for me is to
clarify my thoughts so that i know to
you know because if something is
disturbing you
what that means is that it needs to be
articulated it what it's the emergence
of unexplored territory something that
disturbs you that that's the right way
to think about it it's unmapped
territory that's manifesting itself it's
like a vista of threat and possibility
and you need to articulate a path
through it and so that's what i was
doing it's like i was thinking well this
is bothering me and this seems to be why
and here's what i think is going on and
and so i made the videos and in some
sense i i didn't think anything more of
it there is no faith and no courage and
no sacrifice in doing what is expedient
what do you say to those viewers that
don't pursue their dreams and are locked
into their careers
because they're too afraid to take risks
and pursue something meaningful well the
first thing i would say is
well you should be afraid of taking
risks and pursuing something meaningful
but you should be more afraid of staying
where you are if it's making you
miserable it's like the first thing you
want to do is dispense with the idea
that you get to have any
any permanent security outside of your
ability to contend and adapt it's the
same issue with children it's like
you're paying a price by sitting there
being miserable you might say well the
devil i know is better than the one i
don't it's like don't be so sure of that
the clock is ticking
and if you're miserable in your job now
and you change nothing in five years
you'll be much more miserable and you'll
be a lot older but isn't it the luxury
to pursue what is meaningful our viewers
have mortgages they have children yeah
they have payments and loans it's a
luxury to pursue because we lack the
resources well i don't think i don't
remember now i'm not talking about what
makes you happy
it's a luxury to pursue what makes you
happy it's a moral obligation to pursue
what you find meaningful
and that doesn't mean it's easy it might
require sacrifice if you need to change
your job too let's say you have a family
and and children and a mortgage you have
responsibilities
you've already picked up those
responsibilities you don't just get to
walk away scot-free and say well i don't
like my job i quit that's no strategy
but what you might have to do is you
think well this job is killing my soul
all right so what do i have to do about
that well i have to look for another job
well no one wants to hire me it's like
okay maybe you need to educate yourself
more maybe you need to update your your
curriculum vita your resume maybe you
need to overcome your fear of being
interviewed
maybe you need to sharpen your social
skills like you you have to think about
these things strategically if you're
going to switch careers you have to do
it like an intelligent responsible
person that might take you a couple of
years of of effort i've dealt with
hundreds of people in my clinical and
consulting practice and we set a goal we
develop a vision and work towards it and
it things
inevitably get better for people so it's
not a luxury it's it's difficult it's a
moral responsibility and it isn't
happiness it's it's not the pursuit
isn't for happiness you don't have to
necessarily have done anything wrong for
things to get completely out of control
it's a terrifying doctrine
but it's not a hopeless doctrine because
it still says that there's a way forward
there's a pathway forward and the
pathway forward is to adopt a motive
being that has some nobility
so that you can tolerate yourself and
perhaps even have some respect for
yourself as someone who's capable of
standing up in the face of that terrible
vulnerability and suffering and that the
pathway forward as far as the
existentialists are concerned is by well
certainly by the avoidance of deceit
particularly in language but also by the
adoption of responsibility for the
conditions of existence and some attempt
on your part to actually rectify them
and the thing that's so interesting
about that is that well two as far as
i'm concerned
and some of this is from clinical
experience you know if you take people
and i've told you this and you expose
them voluntarily to things that they are
avoiding and are afraid of you know that
they know they need to overcome in order
to meet their goals their self-defined
goals if you can teach people to stand
up in the face of the things they're
afraid of they get stronger
and you don't know what the upper limits
to that are because you might ask
yourself like if for 10 years if you
didn't avoid doing what you knew you
needed to do by the deaf by your own
definitions right within the value
structure that you've created to the
degree that you've done that what would
you be like
well you know there are remarkable
people who come into the world from time
to time and there are people who do find
out over
decades-long periods what they could be
like if they were who they were if they
said
if they spoke their being forward
and they get stronger and stronger and
stronger and we don't know the limits to
that we do not know the limits to that
and so you could say well in part
perhaps the reason that you're suffering
unbearably can be left at your feet
because you're not everything you could
be and you know it and of course that's
a terrible thing to admit and it's a
terrible thing to consider but there's
real promise in it right because it
means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world and the number
another way that you could act in the
world so what it would reflect back to
you would be much better than what it
reflects back to you now my experience
is with people that we're probably
running at about 51 percent of our
capacity something i mean you can think
about this yourselves i often ask
undergraduates
how many hours a day you waste or how
many hours a week you waste and the
classic answer is something like four to
six hours a day you know inefficient
studying
watching things on youtube that not only
do you not want to watch that you don't
even care about that make you feel
horrible about watching after you're
done that's probably four hours right
there
you know you think well that's 20 25
hours a week it's 100 hours a month
that's two and a half full work weeks
it's half a year of work weeks per year
and if your time is worth
twenty dollars an hour which is a
radical underestimate it's probably more
like 50 if you think about it in terms
of deferred wages if you're wasting 20
hours a week you're wasting 50 000 a
year and you are doing that right now
and it's because you're young wasting 50
000 a year is a way bigger catastrophe
than it would be for me to waste it
because i'm not going to last nearly as
long and so if your life isn't
everything it could be you could ask
yourself well what would happen if you
just stopped wasting the opportunities
that are in front of you
you'd be who knows how much more
efficient 10 times more efficient 20
times more efficient that's the pareto
distribution you have no idea how
efficient efficient people get it's
completely it's off the charts
well and if we all got our act together
collectively and stop making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time not only do they
not do what they should to make things
better they actively attempt to make
things worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or
or homicidal or genocidal or all of
those things all
bundled together in an absolutely
pathological package if people stopped
really really trying just to make things
worse we have no idea how much better
they would get just because of that
so there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability social
judgment
both of which are are are our major
causes of suffering and the failure of
individuals to adopt the responsibility
that they know they should adopt it
isn't merely that your fate depends on
whether or not you get your act together
and to what degree you decide that
you're going to live out your own
genuine being it isn't only your fate
it's the fate of everyone that you're
networked with and so you know you think
well
there's nine billion seven billion
people in the world we're going to peak
at about nine billion by the way and
then it'll decline rapidly but seven
billion people in the world and who are
you you're just one little dust mote
among that seven billion and so it
really doesn't matter what you do or
don't do but that's simply not the case
it's the wrong model because you're at
the center of a network you're a node in
a network of course that's even more
true now that we have social media
you'll you you'll know a thousand people
at least over the course of your life
and they'll know a thousand people each
and that puts you one person away from a
million and two persons away from a
billion
and so that's how you're connected and
the things you do they're like dropping
a stone in a pond the ripples move
outward and they affect things in ways
that you can't fully comprehend and it
means that the things that you do and
that you don't do are far more important
than you think
and so if you act that way of course the
terror of realizing that is that it
actually starts to matter what you do
and you might say well that's better
than living a meaningless existence it's
better for it to matter but i mean if
you really asked yourself would you be
so sure if you had the choice i can live
with no responsibility whatsoever the
price i pay is that nothing matters
or i can reverse it and everything
matters
but i have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that it's not so
obvious to me that people would take the
meaningful path
you know when you say well nihilists
suffer dreadfully because there's no
meaning in their life and they still
suffer yeah but the advantage is they
have no responsibility
so that's the payoff and i actually
think that's the motivation say well i
can't help being nihilistic all my
belief systems have collapsed it's like
yeah maybe
maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out and the
price you pay is some meaningless
suffering but you can always whine about
that and people will feel sorry for you
and you have the option of taking the
pathway of the martyr so that's a pretty
good deal all things considered
especially when they are
when the alternative is to
bear your burden properly and to live
forthrightly in the world well what
solzhenitsyn figured out and so many
people in the 20th century it's not just
him even though he's the best example is
that
if you live a pathological life you
pathologize your society and if enough
people do that then it's hell
really
really
and you can read the gulag archipelago
if you have the fortitude to do that and
you'll see exactly what hell is like and
then you can decide if that's a place
you'd like to visit or even more
importantly if it's a light if it's a
place you'd like to visit and take all
your family and friends
because that's what happened in the 20th
century you can think about
the world this way you can think about
it as your orderly little plan
that's a place and you can think about
it as the place that things that disrupt
your plan comes from that's another
place this is a bigger place
than this
because there's an endless number of
things that can disrupt your plan and
only a tiny number of them that can
you know that will help you work it out
so part of the question then too is like
are you the friend of your plan or are
you the friend of the thing that
disrupts your plan and i would say you
should work to become the friend of the
thing that disrupts your plan because
there's a lot of that
and then if you become the friend of the
thing that disrupts your plan then you
be you start to develop strength in
proportion to the
to the disruptive force and that's
really what you want you want to be able
to implement your plan obviously but you
want to be able to
take on
the consequences of error
and learn from it and then then you win
constantly because even if something
goes sideways you think
there's something to be derived from
this that's wisdom fundamentally plan a
life you'd like to have
and and you do that partly by
referring to social norms that's more or
less rescuing your father from the belly
of the whale but the way other way you
do that is by having a little
conversation with yourself about
as if you don't really know who you are
because you know what you're like you
won't do what you're told you won't do
what you tell yourself to do you must
have noticed that it's like you're a bad
employee and a worse boss and both of
those work
you know for you you don't know what you
want to do and then when you tell
yourself what to do you don't do it
anyways you should fire yourself and
find someone else to be but but you know
what my point is is that you have to
understand that you're not your own
servant so to speak you're someone that
you have to negotiate with and that's
and you're someone that you want to
present the opportunity of having a good
life to and that's hard for people
because they don't like themselves very
much if you configure your life
so that what you are genuinely doing is
aiming at the highest possible good
then the things that you need to
to survive
and to thrive on a day-to-day basis
will deliver themselves to you
that's a hypothesis and it's not some
simple hypothesis right because it what
it basically says is if you dare to do
the most difficult thing that you can
conceptualize your life will work out
better than it will if you do anything
else
well how are you going to find out if
that's true well it's a kierkegaardian
leap of faith there's no way you're
going to find out whether or not that's
true unless you do it so no one no one
can tell you either because just because
it works for someone else i mean that's
interesting and all that but it's no
proof that it'll work for you you have
to be all in in this game there is no
more effective way of operating in the
world than to conceptualize the highest
good that you can and then strive to
attain it there's no
more practical pathway
to the kind of success that you could
have if you actually knew what success
was the world shifts itself around your
aim
because you're you're a creature that
has a name you have to have a name in
order to do something you're an aiming
creature you look at a point and you
move towards it it's built right into
you
and so you have a name well let's say
your aim is the highest possible aim
well then so that sets up the world
around you
it organizes all of your perceptions it
organizes what you see and you don't see
it organizes your emotions and your
motivations
so you organize yourself around that aim
and then what happens is the day
manifests itself as a set of challenges
and problems and if you solve them
properly then you stay on the pathway
towards that aim and you can concentrate
on the on the on the day and so that way
you get to have your cake and eat it too
because you can you can point into the
distance the far distance
and you can live in the day
and it seems to me that that's
that makes every moment of the day
supercharged with meaning that that's
how because if everything that you're
doing every day is related to the
highest possible aim that you can
conceptualize well that's the very
definition of the meaning that would
sustain you in your life i said with
bill c-16 that i wouldn't speak the
language of the radical leftists because
i don't think that that language should
define the game but let's say it does
so here's the game
the world is a battleground of groups
and the they're battling for power
that's it that's the game and some of
them win and they oppress those who
don't win so that's how we're going to
view the world
okay now the leftists say okay well
here's the oppressed people the
oppressors
the patriarchy type patriarchal types
they should be ashamed of themselves and
give up some power
the right wingers the radical
right-wingers look at that and they say
oh i see so the game is ethnic identity
is it
it's identity politics okay
we're white males
we're not going to lose that's the right
wing version of identity politics it's
like screw you
if we're going to divide into groups if
we're going to divide into tribes
and i'm in my tribe
i'm not going to get all guilty and lose
i'm going to get all cruel and win
and that's like then you think well
there's people in the middle they're
kind of looking back and forth which
side of the identity politics spectrum
am i going to fall in do i want to go
with uh do i want to
go
do i want to be driven primarily by
compassion and
am i going to accept guilt for my
historical privilege so that's one
possibility and then i'm the oppressor
i'm the member of the oppressor group or
am i going to say no to hell with that
i'm just going to play to win
well then i'm going to go to the right
it's like well my sense is how about we
don't play either of those games and the
reason we shouldn't play them is well
the soviets played the left-wing game
and like killed
who knows how many tens of millions of
people you can't even count it
accurately the estimates range from 20
to 100 million those are pretty big
error bars and the maoists may be 100
million certainly 60 million
so okay that didn't work out so well
then there's the nazis like they played
ethnic identity politics and racial
superiority it's like why do we want to
play that game
see what i've been trying to do really
what i've been trying to do for the last
30 years is say look
there's heavy temptations to play those
sorts of games
but that's not the only game in town
it's a much better game to play
individual it's like get your act
together
stand up in the world make something of
yourself stay away from the ideological
oversimplifications
set your house in order that's rule six
in the in the in this book so i have a
book rule in there says set your house
in perfect order before you criticize
the world and it's a
very dark chapter about the motivations
of the columbine high school killers and
this other guy named carl panzram who
was a serial rapist and arsonist and
murderer and these he wrote an
autobiography and the columbine kids
also wrote about why they did what they
did they're resentful to the core bitter
bitter resentful
terrible
and
well i'm suggesting that people stay
away from that resentment resentfulness
and bitterness even though life is hard
and and there's malevolence in the world
it's like yeah you can you can tell a
story where everyone's a victim
because we all die we all get sick
you know and and and things happen to us
that are
bitter and terrible betrayal deceit lies
like people hurt us on purpose you know
so it's not just the tragedy of life
it's malevolence as well everyone's a
victim you can tell that story the
problem is if you tell that story and
you start to act it out you make all of
that worse
that's the problem
and it's so this is why partly i got
attracted to christian imagery at least
in part
because there's an idea in christianity
that you should pick up your goddamn
cross and like walk up the hill
and that's
dramatically that's correct
that's the right answer it's like
you've got a heavy load of suffering to
bear and a fair bit of it's going to be
unjust so what are you going to do about
it accept it voluntarily
and try to transform as a consequence
that's the right answer it's the right
answer because the rest of it is
tribalism and
we're we're too technologically powerful
to get all tribal again people have
an
unspecified potential for development
educationally obviously with regards to
the skills they have but also in
relationship to their character and
it's it's much it's much
more encouraging for people i think to
concentrate on who they could be
rather than who they are especially when
they're young because they still have
most of their life ahead of them and
they're not everything they could be yet
and so to tell people even something
like well you should feel good about
yourself the way you are it's like well
that there's something there that's
seriously lacking
because
there's so much more that you could be
that you need to be and that you should
be aiming at just telling you the
problem with being okay the way you are
is that you don't have a goal then and
people need to have a goal in order to
to come to terms with their life this
the baboon here who's supposed to be
basically just a fool when the story was
first written he turned into what's
essentially a shaman across time and so
he represents the self from the union
perspective now the self is everything
you could be across time so imagine that
there's you and there's the potential
inside you whatever that is you know and
potential is an interesting idea because
it represents something that isn't yet
real yet we act like it's real because
people will say to you you should live
up to your potential and that potential
is partly what you could be if you
interacted with the world in a manner
that would gain you the most information
right because you build yourself out of
the information in the piagetian sense
but it's deeper than that too because we
know that if you take yourself and you
put yourself in a new environment new
genes turn on in your nervous system
they encode for new proteins and so
you're full of biological potential that
won't be realized unless you move
yourself around in the world into
different challenging circumstances and
that'll turn on different circuits so
it's not merely that you're
incorporating information from the
outside world in the constructivist
sense it's that by exposing yourself to
different environments you put different
physiological demands on on yourself all
the way down to the genetic level and
that manifests new elements of you and
so one of the things that happens to
people and this is a very common
cultural notion is that you should go on
a pilgrimage at some point to somewhere
central and that would be say like the
rock in the pride rock and the lion king
because you take yourself out of your
dopey little village and that's just the
little bounded you that everyone knows
and that isn't very expanded and then
you go somewhere dark and dangerous to
the central place and while you do that
you have adventures and they toughen you
and pull more out of you like partly
because you're becoming informed which
means in formation it means you're
becoming more organized at every level
of analysis but there's also more of you
too the next best predictor of lifetime
success is conscientiousness well so and
of tho of the two aspects of
conscientiousness say orderliness and
and industriousness the better predictor
is industriousness so the question is
well what can you do about your
industriousness and the answer to that
is
well that's kind of rough too because
there's a strong genetic component but
you can work on micro habits with
regards to your conscientiousness and i
think the best micro habits this is
partly to do with this future authoring
program processes i think the best thing
you can do with regards to your
conscientiousness is to set up some aims
for yourself goals that you actually
value
and the future authoring program helps
people do that and basically it does a
situational analysis of it helps you do
a situational analysis of your life more
than a psychological analysis i would
say and so the questions are something
like well
all right you're going to have to put
some effort into your life and you need
to be motivated to do that and so what
are the potential sources of motivation
well you could think about them in the
big five
manner you know if you're extroverted
you want friends if you're agreeable you
want an intimate relationship if you're
disagreeable you want to win
competitions if you're open you want to
engage in creative activity if you're
high neuroticism you want security okay
so those are all sources of potential
motivation that you could draw on that
you could tailor to your own you know
your own personality but then there are
dimensions that you want to consider
your life across and so we ask people
about well you know if you could have
your life the way you wanted it in three
to five years if you were taking care of
yourself properly you know what would
you want from your friendships what
would you want from your intimate
relationship how would you like to
structure your family what do you want
for your career well how are you going
to use your time outside of your job and
how are you going to regulate your
mental physical mental and physical
health and maybe also your drug and
alcohol use because that's that's a good
place to auger down you know because
alcoholism for example wipes out you
know five to ten percent of people so
you want to keep that under control
and then
and then so maybe you know you you you
develop a vision of what your life what
you would like your life to be and that
associates
the
so the goal once the goal is established
and then you break down the goal into
micro processes that you can implement
the micro processes become rewarding in
proportion in relation to their uh
causal association with the goal and
that tangles in your your incentive
reward system you know we talked about
the dopaminergic incentive reward system
and that's the thing that keeps you
moving forward and the way it works is
that it works better
if
it produces positive emotion when it can
see you moving towards a valued goal
okay well what's the implication of that
better have a valued goal because
otherwise you can't get any positive
motivation working out and so the more
valuable the goal in principle the more
the micro processes associated with that
goal start to take on a positive charge
and so what that means is while you get
up in the morning and you're excited
about the day you're ready to go and so
as far as i can tell what you do is you
specify your long-term ideal
maybe you also specify a place you want
to stay the hell away from so that
you're terrified to fail as well as
excited about succeeding because that's
also useful you specify your goal you do
that
you do that in some sense as a unique
individual you want you want to specify
goals that make you say oh if that could
happen as a consequence of my efforts it
would clearly be worthwhile because the
question always is why do something
because doing nothing is easy you just
sit there and you don't do anything
that's real easy the question is why
would you ever do anything and the
answer that has to be because you've
determined by some means that it's
worthwhile and then the next question
might be well where should you look for
worthwhile things and one would be well
you could consult your own temperament
and the other would be well you kind of
look at how
look at what it is that people accrue
that's valuable across the lifespan
look look what so you do a structural
analysis of the subcomponents of human
existence and already did that
you need a family you need friends like
you don't need to have all these things
but you better have most of them family
friends career educational goals plans
for you know time outside of work
attention to your mental and physical
health etc you know those are that's
what life is about and if you don't have
any of those things well then all you've
got left is misery and suffering so
that's that's a bad
that's a bad deal for you
so
so once you but once you set up that
that goal structure let's say and that's
really in many in many ways that's what
you should be doing at universities is
that's exactly what you should be doing
is trying to figure out
who it is that you're trying to be
right and you you aim at that and then
you use everything you learn as a means
of building that person that you want to
be and
and i really mean want to be i don't
mean should be even those things those
things are going to overlap and it's
important to distinguish between those
because that's partly and this is back
down to the micro routine analysis so i
saying well you're going to try to make
yourself more industrious okay number
one specify your damn goals because how
are you going to hit something if you
don't know what it is that isn't going
to happen and often people won't specify
their goals too because they don't like
to specify conditions for failure so if
you keep yourself all vague and foggy
which is real easy because that's just a
matter of not doing as well then you
don't know when you fail
and people might say well i really don't
want to know when i fail because that's
painful so i'll keep myself blind about
when i fail that's fine except you'll
fail all the time then you just won't
know it until you've failed so badly
that you're done
and that can easily happen by the time
you're 40.
so so
i would recommend that you don't let
that happen so that's willful blindness
right you could have known but you chose
not to okay so once you get your goal
structure set up you think okay if i
could have this life it looks like that
might be worth living despite the fact
that it's going to be you know
anxiety provoking and threatening and
there's going to be some suffering and
loss involved in all of that obviously
the goal is to to have a vision for your
life such that all things considered
that justifies your effort i started to
pay very careful attention to
what i was saying
i don't know if that happened
voluntarily or involuntarily but i could
feel a sort of split developing in my
psyche and the split and i've actually
had students tell me the same thing has
happened to them
after they've
listened to some of the material that
that i've been describing to all of you
but
i split into two
let's say
and one part was the let's say the old
me that was talking a lot
and that
liked to argue and that liked ideas and
there was another part that was watching
that part like just with its eyes open
and neutrally judging
and the part that was neutrally judging
was watching the part that was talking
and going
that isn't your idea you don't really
believe that
you don't really know what you're
talking about
that isn't true and i thought hmm that's
really interesting so now i've and that
was happening to like 95 of what i was
saying and so then i didn't really know
what to do i thought okay this is
strange so maybe i've fragmented and
that's just not a good thing at all i
mean it wasn't like i was hearing voices
or anything like that i mean it wasn't
like that
it was it was well people
have multiple parts so then i had a this
weird conundrum is like
well which of those two things are me
is it the part that's listening and
saying no that's rubbish that's a lie
that's
you're doing that to impress people
you're just trying to win the argument
you know
was that me or was the part that was
going about my normal verbal business me
and i didn't know but i decided i would
go with the critic and then what i'd
tried to do what i learned to do i think
was to stop saying things that made me
weak
and now that i mean i'm still trying to
do that because i'm always
feeling when i talk
whether or not the words that i'm saying
are either making me align or making me
come apart
and i think the alignment i really do
think the alignment is i think alignment
is the right way of conceptualizing it
because i think if you say things that
are
as true as you can say them let's say
then they come up
they come out of the depths inside of
you because we don't know where thoughts
come from we don't know how far down
into your substructure the thoughts
emerge we don't know what processes of
physiological alignment are necessary
for you to speak from the core of your
being we don't understand any of that we
don't even conceptualize that but i
believe that you can feel that and i
learned some of that from reading carl
rogers by the way who's a great
clinician
because he talked about mental health in
part as the coherence between the
the
the spiritual or the or the abstract and
the physical that the two things were
aligned and and there's a lot of idea of
alignment in in psychoanalytic and
clinical thinking
but anyways i decided that i would start
practicing not saying things that would
make me weak and what happened was that
i had to stop saying almost everything
that i was saying i would say 95 of it
as a hell of a shock to wake up and i
mean this was over a few months but it's
a hell of a shock to wake up and realize
that you're mostly dead wood
it's a shock
you know and you might think well do you
really want all of that to burn off it's
like well there's nothing left but a
little husk five percent of you it's
like well if that five percent is
solid
then maybe that's exactly what you want
to have happen adopt the mode of
authentic being
and that is something like
refusing to participate in
the lie in deception in the lie to
orient your speech as much as you can
towards the truth
and to take responsibility for your own
life and perhaps also for the lives of
other people and there's something about
that that's
meaningful and responsible and noble but
also serves to mitigate the very
suffering that produces
say the nihilism or the flea into the
arms of flea or or the or the escape
into the arms of totalitarians to begin
with
you need something to shelter you
against your own vulnerability my
primary motive as a clinical
psychologist and educator is to help
individuals live
more meaningful and productive lives in
harmony with their families and their
community that's my motive
and the evidence for that i think is
well if people go online and first of
all you can watch the lectures and
decide for yourself but you can also go
there's i suspect probably
maybe 250 000 people have commented on
the lectures and their effects on them
and so
that's what people say i'm watching the
lectures yeah i'm trying to develop a
vision for my life i'm trying to become
more responsible and it's really helping
and that's and that's what i hear all
the time when i do these public lectures
which which aren't political but when we
gain success we raise the bar
we set our ambitions higher i mean what
is your end game what do you want that's
all that's what i want i want i want to
help as many individuals as possible
become more courageous
more truthful
and more engaged in the pursuit of
individual familial and social harmony
that's what i want if you're failing
repeatedly
then there's probably something wrong
it's possible that there's something
wrong with the way that you're
conceptualizing the world because you
have a choice right if if you keep
making sacrifices and they don't work
there's a binary choice and one is well
there's something
wrong with the structure of reality
and the other is there's something wrong
with your approach
and so then you might say well let's
take the first idea there's something
wrong with the structure of reality it's
like you're really going to say that are
you you're really going to come out and
say i know enough to judge the nature of
being
and
and then the alternative is also quite
frightening because then you know you
it's you that's making the mistakes and
you might be wrong at a really deep
level and that might mean that a lot of
you has to burn off
and be transformed maybe even things
about yourself that you think are
admirable and that you like because your
position you know your your self
conceptualization is so warped and wrong
and that's really daunting but you know
when people set themselves up as the
judge of being i mean i've written about
this a fair bit in my new book which is
called 12 rules for life
when people set themselves up as the
judge of being then they take on what
can only be described as a kind of
satanic arrogance because they've
actually
taken to themselves the moral right to
criticize the structure of existence
itself it's like you better be careful
when you do something like that because
you're setting yourself up as the judge
of being and the columbine kids did that
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you're special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome if you want to see my
recent top 10 rules success video from
jordan peterson check the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there it doesn't disgrace you in some
sense that that might be a good way to
think about it and you don't want to
disgrace yourself because the
consequence of disgrace is emotional
dysregulation more pain less positive
emotion